soweit ich jetzt weiß das cosmo
auffällig geworden auf dem schulhof
weiter da war herzog solange leute ich
bin heute wieder für euch da mit einer
neuen reaction das video ist uns heute
reinziehen werden kommt aus unserer
community und zwar von pe unterstrich
tat mir auch instagram zwei videos
geschickt eines davon ist das was wir
uns heute einziehen werden heute viele
kampeter wenn die aufpassen sollten bio
habt dann folgt mir auf instagram und
schickt mir auch instagram at&s gezockt
irgendwelche queens videos die er
irgendwo im internet gefunden habt wird
sie uns heute eine klinik am südring
folge reihen leute die ich könnte
bisschen wissen funky werden der titel
ist besonderes spielzeug in der schule
was will schüler kosten damit dekkers
will damit also ok power weg der typ a
ist cosmo werfen weil man blick in die
beschreibung für die story aber erst
herantragen schon geil
kennt ihr diese situation wenn man ein
fachmann ist mutter in dem moment wo der
sohn der eine sohn nach hause kommt von
der schule könnte man sich einfach einen
schluck aus einer mineralwasserflasche
ohne logos ist nicht auch mit lieblings
mineralwasser das komplett ohne logos
kann aber leute werfen kurze
beschreibung die beschreiben erwartet
mutter leonis alarmiert als sohn cosmo
12 von der schule nach hause gebracht
wird weil er auf dem schulhof mit einem
vfb ler gebracht hat dann stellt sich
auch noch heraus dass der schüler das
geklaut hat
[Musik]
der check das fahrzeug war sein blick
das ist also new york
ich versuche gar einzusetzen stell dir
vor du bist in der situation so du bist
irgendwie so lucky star ist eine
pubertät so als junge die parteien gehen
geht mit dem du denkst du aber immer
dicker heute bringe ich mal allen
ernstes man wie mit in die schule
lehrern bemerkt dass du wirst nach hause
geschickt und in dem moment hier in
diesem hier realisieren was für eine von
der schule selbst so kurz vorm bist du
zwölf jahre alt als schauspieler müssen
die demütige sagte muss so eine rolle
schauspieler von dem jungen der aus
unerfindlichen gründen einen okay leute
ich benutze ist ein codewort ja ich
brauche das codewort adler für das wort
vwr und so weiter und so fort damit
youtube mich komplett band also der
einen adler mit in die schule bringen
klar dass er sich weg also dass jetzt
ein familienhelfer wissen ja ist ja
immer also klingt am südring spieler
immer im krankenhaus familien hält weil
sich ein psychotherapeut und ja also ich
weiß nicht was im echten leben außer ist
wahrscheinlich ist das sogar ziemlich
ecke die psychotherapeutin und
therapeutinnen meistens sind immer so
ein bisschen die sind ein bisschen ein
bisschen funky wisst ihr das ist ein
bisschen anders drauf
dem zwölfjährigen sohn cosmote er ist
sehr auffällig geworden auf dem schulhof
weil er da eine große versammlung
erzeugt hat er hat damit nur darum
geprallt
leute was auch was wir auch ich habe
gleich meine ich mache mich hier sogar
lustig so denkt man dass das meiner
schulzeit mein leben meine karriere
komplett beenden okay aber egal wie wie
braten damit das wie gibt man damit an
den zwölf jahre alt ich gehe zu meinem
freund die auch selbst oder das geht
überhaupt nicht aber ich habe ja noch
versprochen die eine story zum beispiel
zweiter gehört ich weiß nichts erzählen
soll ich jetzt machen und zwar weil es
in der grundschule
da hatte ich auf irgendeine art und
weise ein ein tampon irgendwie bekommen
wir die hände bekommen so und darf ist
ein mädchen die schule genommen und habe
dann bin also leuten hinterher gerannt
hast du getan also selbst von
silvesterböller willst du so tisch kann
also dran ziehen kann
ich werde alles muss ich nichts sagen
[Musik]
war bruder horst becker das ist das bild
das geht nicht da ich meine es schon von
wanda getrennt
das waren wir außen vor gelassen stellen
bei diesen konzentrationen vor so wie
gesagt also zwölfjährige sind manchmal
gestört aber irgendwo checken dies dann
auch wieder was gerade am frequency
verpackt haben danach schickt man es ja
meistens im magic alter bis zu hause und
eine psychotherapeut kommt wegen dieser
sache und hält dann vor versammelter
mannschaft dieses ding hier unter der
mutter vor und ein alarmstufe rot raum
gespielt hat das lachen aber dann merkt
auf einen krassen unterschied zwischen
schauspielern und tatsächlich
betroffenen also echten szenarien an
beiden stellen bevor der junge junge
wäre kein schauspieler sondern dass
irgendein grund bittet werde ist
wirklich so gefilmt worden wie es
irgendwo passiert ist in unserer familie
kein mensch will da lachen glaube ich
würde so krank wie das ist keine es
keine bananen ich bin total perplex du
bist doch erst zwölf wo hast du das ding
überhaupt her
das einzige was eine dieser situation
tröstet ist wirklich zu wissen dass das
geschauspielert ist ich glaube ich kann
mich einfach gut rein fühlt weil ich
selbst so ein
so ein kind war was viel gebaut hat und
dann so oft diese situation hat wo man
zu hause war mit der eigenen mutter und
vielleicht auch in einer person
und da gesagt wurde dass das für falsch
gemacht dass man nicht immer so
empfunden
also das verzichten gehört habe war dass
er nicht nur das hat sondern dass der
sichtlichen auflauf produziert hat auf
dem schulhof und seinen freunden gezeigt
hatte ein bisschen damit geprahlt hat
sich sechs dinger wie breit man damit
sagt sie mir bitte mal schreibt man die
kommentare heute wie kann man mit sowas
prallen könnte sich erklären ich glaub
nicht ich sehe eure kommentare
kein mensch kann nichts erklären es geht
nicht das geht überhaupt nicht wie du
hast geklaut ja ja ja aber dann doch
nicht eigentlich war das kaufland ich
keinen bock mehr ich weiß es nicht leute
also einerseits wirklich auch haben wir
noch eine eigenen kinder irgendwie
klauen würden oder so aber wieder so ein
drama draus gemacht wird hat er halt mal
jemanden abgerückt
ok also so schlecht eigentlich
fast schon peinlich und habe ich in
deine tasche
kossmann zugegeben dass er lacht
länderliste ja weil dieses gewichtiger
es ist so krank ich habe nach seiner
mutter so o mein gott ich habe jeden
einzelnen schritt in der erziehung eines
kindes falsch gemacht ich bin eine
schlechte mutter
wie verhindere ich dass mein kind
drogenabhängig wird und dem cluster
anders und deren bist du eigentlich
verhält er sich ganz normal die noten
sind auch ganz normal und immer noch gut
dieses zusammenhangs zu den noten
bestehen weil ich jetzt wirklich nicht
also liebe mutter von cosmo ich muss das
an der stelle betont er muss erstmal mit
dem verlust von wanda hinwegkommen
ja und dann das macht er ja schon gut er
schaut mir gute noten aber dieses
argument wirklich keinen sinn so dass
schüler die in drei schnitt haben oder
schlechter die bringen häufiger seltsame
sachen mit in die schule ist ein
bisschen für mich die frage hast du
eigentlich los in deinem leben ich habe
jetzt gehört die eltern haben sich
getrennt
das ist immer ein schmerz manchmal ein
paar nicht mehr als einheit zu haben
aber der job also so langsam ich kann
kostenlos ein bisschen nachvollziehen
muss ich sagen ich kenne das aus eigener
erfahrung leute wenn solche sachen
passieren wie die jetzt dass die eigenen
eltern sich trennen was großen druck
ausübt erfinder natürlich dann fängt man
an wo jedes zu machen
es ist einfach so dass ich sage dass es
das macht man einfach dann der eigene
kopf muss irgendwie dieser wir diese
größeren belastung dieser komplexität
und sicherheit klar kommt und dann macht
man einfach häufiger kostenlos sein
sollte dann hat jetzt aber sogar auch
schon eine neue freundin und die frage
ist wie wohl fühlst du dich wenn du
diese frau scheint schnell leute würde
ich meine ich will keine psycho
therapeut irgendwas ich hab keine
fachausbildung gelte aber dieser diese
frage dieser schutz ist ein bisschen
geld also also ok kosten und einen adler
mit in die schule geschleppt und hat
damit vor seinen freunden angegeben was
ist mit der neuen frau von seinem vater
die das ist der einzige grund dafür dass
so was passiert dass die neue frau vom
vater
du hast doch so schöne sachen offen
zugeben darf ich die benutzen könnten
wir jetzt auch missverstehen
also wenn man annimmt dass ist dass
dieses blöde ding nicht das einzige was
kosten glücklich weil man mit schülern
halt auf dem schulhof mitreden
also ja ich bin immer so da außen vor
ist
es ist klar leute ok daraus können wir
glaube ich eine schnelle schluss
cutscene leute wenn ihr bei euren
mitschülern manchmal nicht mitreden
können bei manchen themen dann ist es
keine lösung wenn ihr eines tages einen
adler mit auf den schulhof schleppt und
diesen adler dann freudig präsentiert
macht einfach nicht alle im echten leben
geht es noch mehr grip also dieser folge
für die jüngeren da draußen redet
einfach mit einem eltern reden mit
eltern geschwistern oder so die euch
dazu was erzählen kann und was mich so
was hier finden sie darüber natürlich
vorschlages regierung kann aber gottes
schickt mir immer wenn ihr kind videos
findet die an es geht sagt auf instagram
und folgt mir das wort von mir leute ich
bin raus was gut